la vie reprend peu à peu dans les rues
de la ville sainte depuis jeudi celle de
sport centres commerciaux et marchés
sont autorisés à reprendre leurs
activités
après deux mois de confinement la
population israélienne peut de nouveau
circuler à condition de respecter les
consignes de sécurité
la distanciation physique et de rigueur
dans les commerces et le port du masque
obligatoire dans les lieux publics sous
peine d'amendé les habitants de
jérusalem sont heureux de pouvoir
ressortir mais reste néanmoins sur leurs
gardes
nous devons faire attention à rester
éloigné des gens à l'hygiène à garder
nos masques et j'espère je crois que
l'on retrouvera nos vies normales
sinon ce n'est pas possible on ne peut
pas rester chez nous les gens
deviendrais fou je me sens en sécurité
j'ai toujours mon gel hydroalcoolique
mon masque et 9
je ne touche personne mais je me sens en
sécurité je n'ai pas peur
plus maintenant après deux mois de mise
en sommeil le marché du quartier
historique de manet yehuda a lui aussi
repris son activité
une réouverture sous haute surveillance
son accès n'est autorisée qu'après
vérification de la température des
entrants pourtant malgré ces mesures les
clients sont bien de retour
quant aux commerçants ils sont ravis et
entendent désormais relancer leurs
activités
je suis resté à la maison pendant deux
mois j'ai perdu de l'argent ce n'est pas
bien je suis revenu pour travailler pour
l'argent je veux gagner ma vie je suis
très content de revenir pendant deux
mois je suis resté assis à cause de ce
problème dans le monde
je reviens je suis très content je veux
travailler pas rester assis alors que la
communauté israélite a dû passer pessah
la pâque juive à l'isolément la vie
religieuse a aussi repris son cours
symbole de la ville le mur des
lamentations est de nouveau accessible
depuis ce jeudi
plusieurs espaces ont été aménagés afin
de permettre laquelle des fidèles dont
chaque section 10 personnes peuvent
ainsi se rassembler pour prier
où célébrer les bar mitzvah une forme de
renaissance pour ce lieu emblématique où
carrefour des trois religions
monothéistes